[Musica]
Miriam da ridere perché quando vanno
invitato e questo evento che diciamo che
è importantissimo straordinario detto ma
io che c'entro Sì faccio il cuoco a
qualcuno di voi possa essere simpatico
ma tutte queste cose le vedo soprattutto
questa parola Coraggio Coraggio delle
idee poi oggi come sempre che io sono un
improvvisatore Infatti proprio oggi
parlavo con uno dei contatori non diceva
ascrivi i testi quando tu fai i video no
è tutto abbraccia pure le ricette tutte
ricette che vedete che vi che vi do su
tutte ricette che normalmente vedo e
improvviso mentre faccio la spesa quello
che ti racconto pane video e faccio
quelle modifiche all'ultimo momento
infatti chiamerà dopo aver voglia di
grida sempre
e
quindi tornando a questa parola coraggio
pensavo ho scritto oggi
devi dire alcune parole di alcuni
momenti della mia vita e ho pensato
quando c'è stato in me questa questa
atto coraggioso di cambiare qualcosa
è iniziato con la disgrazia
che mi ha lasciato
un ricordo bello preciso una bella
ferita dentro di me quando Io vendo mio
padre cinquantenne e molti infatti
infatti ho sentito il professore e a
Roma con mezz'ora non era malato
perché
ho iniziato a lavorare il mio lavoro è
un'azienda io padre e mi trovo a che
fare con socio e quello cattivo quello
che ti vuole mettere subito all'anno
perché sei il quello che è rimasto il
giovane e che vuole subito fare tutto
quanto con le fregate tutto quanto
io devo fare quello che veramente ti
piace fare
a noi è sempre piaciuta la cucina solo
che il tuo padre che voleva che io
entrassi nell'azienda un'azienda come
storica nata il 1590
un percorso e con un po' di coraggio in
una situazione che era molto complicata
perché non ce l'ha lasciato tempi ma non
aveva lasciato soldi
mi ricordo che sul conto Cerco appena 5
milioni di lire notevole Quindi devono
pagare la successione dopo fa tante cose
e dove troverete questa nuova lavoro
fare quello che a me piace veramente il
cuoco l'amica inizia subito a fare il
cuoco quindi non sono un percorso
veramente duro che la prima cosa che
hanno fatto ha fatto la scopa
e il primo lavoro non pagato era Quindi
inizia la fuorileggerire questa a posto
la spesa Garibaldi
che è successo È successo che io ho
avuto sempre
tanta forza di
assistere di essere
diciamo molto paziente e di osservare
gli altri e piano piano piano piano
piano piano piano ho acquisito
un'esperienza fino a quando un giorno è
successo che
è capitato Io dico che la vita
la fortuna della vita e soprattutto data
dagli incontri una persona che dice
guarda
è un suo
punto quando tu fai in cucina e poi
quando fai qualsiasi altro mestiere c'è
sempre quello che vuole mostrare che lui
ha studiato ha fatto anche chiedere loro
hanno fatto alberghiero che anche per
vedere quindi facevano una scuola
serrati alberghiera e questo progetto
invece vuole dire con noi vieni a fare
l'assistente nuovi e incomincio questa
cosa dopo tante esperienze in cucina
perché sono quasi 32 anni che il cuscino
Entro a far parte del Gambero Rosso e
manco fare quello che aiutava i cuochi a
fare ricette per il video è stato anche
papà di Deborah il grande maestro
però che è successo durante questi anni
io mi sentivo di lavorare per qualcuno e
di non essere me stesso a un certo punto
con mia moglie e recentemente cinque
anni fa lei è una stratega dice proprio
un video
e abbiamo iniziato a fare dei video per
YouTube e questi video Hanno cominciato
a andare
fortissimo perché abbiamo iniziato nel
fine 2017 inizio 18 proprio in
precedenza Parigi e
sono successe tante cose però diciamo
sempre una un'idea quella di
promuovere solo esclusivamente le cose
che per prima a me piacevano
Quindi con cosa ho fatto ho avuto anche
in questo caso il coraggio di rinunciare
al guadagno al grande guadagno per
promuovere quello che per me era la cosa
più che più vi rendeva orgoglioso i
prodotti la nostra italianità i nostri
piccoli gioielli di produttori di olio
che la magia del produttore d'olio è
così poi capita la stagione che c'è
qualcosa che gela oppure fa troppo caldo
piove troppo e niente va sotto Quindi ho
fatto tutto gratuitamente
passo con il tempo passo del tempo e
andavamo questi di offrire un sacco di
soldi cioè all'epoca mi ricordo
All'inizio c'era un'azienda che offri
40.000 euro per fare tre video che
ancora oggi ci penso ammazza Quanti
soldi e gli ho detto di no dopo un po'
quell'azienda la vedo sorpresa diretta
che viene fatto
un colpo giornalistico e ho fatto bene a
non accettare
ho continuato questo percorso e poco
tempo fa
mi hanno fatto anche Ambasciatore delle
prove d'Italia perché è questo senso
molto orgoglioso perché noi ci abbiamo
questi gioielli pazzeschi che poi
conoscono il mondo e di noi abbiamo il
diritto come dei piccoli Panda di
salvaguardarli perché sono tante persone
che lavorano per noi che noi non
sappiamo da Chi coltiva da chi alleva da
Chi produce gli italiani che fanno un
lavoro
meraviglioso col cuore con la passione e
non vengono tante volte tutelati e io
costantemente i miei video in quello che
faccio cerco sempre di tutelare queste
persone di sponsorizzare queste persone
a un certo punto proviene da cosa
che tutti i video che facevo quindi il
guadagno che proveniva da YouTube
dalle pubblicità che fa YouTube
all'interno dei nostri video crollato ho
detto Mannaggia Che è successo questo
qua è successo non lo fa e ci guardiamo
e mia moglie stavamo in vacanza ho detto
questo è successo qualcosa non andiamo
più di moda non sono più carini
è uscito il boom dei Mille e i video
verticali tutti quelli che noi facciamo
Costruiamo facciamo così io vi voglio
che guarda dico ma io ho trovato
questo tutti i ragazzini che ballano e
si muovono scattano parlano poco
fanno molti effetti di luce dei suoli
tutto quanto resto io che sto
chiacchierone riesco Diciamo tra
virgolette intrattenere a fare eventi
fare queste cose Domani iniziamo questo
percorso il 15
luglio il 15 luglio cominciamo a fare
dei video appositamente per due
Social che sono abbastanza giovanili Tik
Tok
e il primo che abbiamo iniziato a
valorizzare a fare delle cose proprio
per loro e poi Instagram
da qui studio oggi è successo questo
abbiamo preso circa 300.000 follower al
mese su Tik Tok arrivando a 3 milioni e
400 mila oggi e abbiamo preso circa
100.000 follower al mese su Instagram
arrivavano un milione 400 mila follower
adesso
Allora
io voglio dire che noi dobbiamo avere il
coraggio di fare quello che realmente
crediamo che crediamo perché solo questo
è quella cosa che ci rende vincenti
perché tutte le volte che facciamo e mi
è capitato anche a me fare qualcosa che
non volevo
controvoglia solo un fattore di denaro
sono un fattore di perché così che
faccio lavorare perché così c'è questa
cosa e ho sempre sbagliato quindi quello
che vi voglio condividere
è quello di cercare di fare di voler
fare assolutamente solamente quello che
veramente vi piace sicuramente qualcuno
dirà sarebbe meglio l'uomo oggi che la
carica domani
io ho preferito la gallina di domani e
ho fatto tante cose gratuitamente e oggi
ne ricevo diciamo
con orgoglio anche questo invito Insomma
che è importante l'ultima cosa non
trascurabile è quella che a un certo
punto abbiamo detto
cinquantenne può
adesso imparare l'inglese perché non
L'idea era quella Ma qui ma fuori
dall'Italia Ma che se magnano che hai
pensato dalla nostra cultura del nostro
Circo delle nostre cose buone di un Pane
e Pomodoro e olio che può essere
esperienza stratosferica fatta col
pomodoro
buono estivo quello giusto con pane no
quello comprato da baguette congelata
che si occupa al supermercato e poi dal
fornaio che da una mamma a papà quello
che sia e con quell'olio che quando
appena apri la bottiglia Senti quel
profumo che tenervia che senti i profumi
di quella terra Se ti propone il
territorio questa cosa gli altri non la
sanno e anche alcune di noi non lo sanno
quindi ho detto facciamo così
Incominciamo con l'inglese incominciamo
a
a far cadere la gente ha fatto via gli
altri quello che per noi è già
importante non è solo semplicemente dire
olio extravergine d'oliva la Renault è
importante dire da dove viene quell'olio
extravergine di oliva che
settorializzativa se si sente pomodoro
verde se si sente il carciofo se si
sente la foglia di basilico all'interno
e abbiamo cominciato questa percorso con
dell'inglese allora qualche italiano
subito mi ha detto ma avevo dice sempre
con l'H iniziale così invece gli altri
parlanti vanno ero già otto grazie che
stai impegnando per farci capire quello
che è la cucina italiana
oggi noi abbiamo il 45% dei follower che
sono angolo parlanti l'interesse del
mondo quindi gli Stati Uniti Canada
Inghilterra Brasile
qual è quello che vi dico io quello che
vorrei dirti
Prima di tutto è
di avere degli obiettivi della vita
perché tanto nessuno ci porterà al
successo siamo soltanto noi che siamo
arrivati al successo quindi nessuno ci
capirà perché c'è una cosa fantastica da
fare ti porterò a diventare questo
Almeno per me è capitato Non so voi
dipende solamente
da noi E da quello che realmente
vogliamo fare della vita
un'altra cosa che io ritengo
importante che è stata veramente
strategica per me è quella che ha
rispetto a che punto di quello che
facevo in tv con gli altri a casa mia
faccio come mi pare parlo come mi pare
dico quello che voglio e per questo
gran parte di voi mi apprezza per questo
oggi che lavorare Qual è la conclusione
Qual è quella che voglio dire non hanno
morale della Costituzione che non posso
fatturare a nessuno perché sono
solo il peggio di tutti che sono felice
che avrei avuto questo coraggio
dimostrare veramente me stesso e non di
nascondermi non di targare un po' e di
far vedere quello che realmente non ero
Cerco in qualche modo di insegnarlo a
mio figlio
e la cosa più importante che cerco di
condividerlo con tutti voi grazie ai
Social Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]